celui-ci gauche j'espère que vous allez
bien comme promis on passe en revue le
programme de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle et aujourd'hui
nouvelles candidates on se retrouve pour
décrypter le programme de nathalie
arthaud en dix mesures alors si jamais
vous êtes nouveau bienvenue en plus de
ces décryptage des programmes des
candidats j'interviewe aussi tous les
candidats dans un format inédit
d'interviews face cachée donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne pour ne
pas louper tout ça les vidéos qui
viennent
avant de commencer petit point sur le
parcours de nathalie arthaud elle à 51
ans elle est enseignante agrégé
d'économie et de gestion
depuis 2008 elle est la porte parole du
parti d'extrême gauche lutte ouvrière un
parti qui a pour projet général de
défendre les salariés et les personnes
les plus pauvres face aux patrons face
au financier et à ce qu'elle appelle
plus largement les puissants nathalie
arthaud se définit comme communiste
révolutionnaire est allé pour un
renversement de la société et des
rapports de force concrètement elle
souhaite que les travailleurs reprennent
par exemple le contrôle des entreprises
et des moyens de production et ce pour
selon elle permettre une meilleure
redistribution des richesses c'est sa
troisième candidature à l'élection
présidentielle son programme est plus ou
moins le même que celui qu'elle avait en
2012 où elle avait obtenu près de 0 5%
des voix ou en 2017 où elle avait obtenu
un score assez similaire à l'est par
ailleurs souvent représenté comme
l'héritière d'arlette laguiller arlette
laguiller est issu du même parti lutte
ouvrière et c'était la première femme à
se présenter à une élection
présidentielle en 1974
enfin élément assez important à noter
même si jamais elle est candidate à la
présidentielle nathalie arthaud a
toujours dit qu'elle ne visait pas
vraiment le poste de présidente de la
république ce que ça veut dire c'est que
son programme n'est pas forcément une
liste détaillée de toutes les mesures à
mettre en place et la façon de les
mettre en place puisque de fait ce qui
est surtout portée par nathalie arthaud
eh bien c'est la sortie complète du
capitalisme et la création d'un tout
nouveau modèle de société un peu comme
philippe poutou d'ailleurs pour mieux
comprendre tout ça est bien l'interview
de nathalie arthaud devrait aussi vous
permettre d'y voir plus clair alors
première mesure nathalie arthaud
souhaite supprimer la tva c'est une taxe
qui est payé par chacun d'entre vous à
chaque fois que l'on achète un produit
ou alors qu'on utilise un service vous
le voyez en général sur votre ticket de
caisse fait taxes donc qui va ensuite
dans les caisses de l'état est estimé
injuste par nathalie arthaud puisque
tout le monde l'appelle de la même façon
en achetant des produits alors que tout
le monde n'a pas forcément les mêmes
moyens et les mêmes revenus alors
supprimer la tva ça veut forcément dire
moins d'argent pour l'état mais du coup
pour compenser tous à nathalie arthaud
propose par exemple d'augmenter les
taxes sur les profits notamment des
grandes entreprises deuxième mesure
nathalie arthaud souhaite qu'aucun
salaire et qu aucune pension de retraite
ne soit inférieur à 2000 euros net alors
qu'aujourd'hui le salaire minimum est de
1200 sont 9 euros net alors pour
financer une telle mesure nathalie
arthaud compte là aussi notamment
prendre davantage sur les profits des
multinationales et des grandes
entreprises françaises troisième mesure
nathalie arthaud un objectif de zéro
chômeur en france et elle compte y
parvenir de deux manières d'abord
première chose elle souhaite réduire la
durée de temps de travail sans baisser
les salaires de façon à ce que le
travail soit davantage réparties au sein
de la population ça rejoint à la
proposition de pas mal le candidat à
gauche aujourd'hui la règle de base
c'est les 35 heures certains candidats
souhaitent passer par exemple aux 32
heures elle valait encore plus en
l'occurrence lorsque j'ai interviewé il
ya quelques jours elle a évoqué par
exemple l'idée de bosser deux à trois
heures par jour avec le même salaire
donc deux à trois heures par jour ça
ferait donc des semaines à 15 heures
environ soit beaucoup moins que ce qui
est en place aujourd'hui au passage là
dessus dit comme ça dans le système
actuel ça peut paraître extrêmement
difficile à appliquer si ce n'est
d'ailleurs complètement impossible c'est
là où c'est très important de noter que
une telle chose selon elle ne pourrait
se faire que dans un cadre de société
radicalement nouveau une société où l'on
met complètement sortie du capitalisme
est sorti de l'économie de marché
autrement dit pas la société actuelle
l'autre grande proposition de nathalie
arthaud pour parvenir à son objectif de
zéro chômeur c'est l'interdiction des
miss simon c'est une mesure qui est
également porté par philippe poutou le
candidat du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste et en cas de faute
professionnelle d'un salarié ce ne
serait pas aux patrons mais aux autres
travailleurs de l'entreprise de décider
du sort de ce salarié comme le candidat
de gauche de la faune se sont mises jean
luc mélenchon nathalie arthaud veut par
ailleurs faire passer l'âge de la
retraite à taux plein donc avec le
montant maximum possible à 60 ans
aujourd'hui la règle générale c'est
qu'il faut attendre 65 ans 4e promesses
de campagne de nathalie arthaud
supprimer complètement les frais
d'inscription à l'université et
augmenter les bourses étudiantes sachant
que au moment on tourne cependant elle
n'a pas encore précisé le montant de
cette hausse de bourse cinquième mesure
cette fois ci sur le volet santé
nathalie arthaud souhaite que tous les
soins de santé prescrit par un médecin
soit gratuit pour tous est prise en
charge dans son intégralité par
l'assurance maladie selon elle cette
mesure peut être financé en prenant sur
les profits des grands groupes
industriels notamment pharmaceutiques et
de la finance en effet à l'heure
actuelle tous les soins ne sont pas
rembourser dans leur intégralité dans le
pays si elle mesure qui concerne la
présence de militaires français à
l'étranger selon la candidate nathalie
arthaud les guerres menées à l'étranger
son jeu site menées pour le profit et
jamais dans l'intérêt des peuples
autrement dit donc elle veut y mettre
fin et aujourd'hui les forces armées
françaises sont déployées pour deux
grandes opérations majeures notamment
pour l'opération barkan au sahel et au
sahara donc en afrique ainsi que
l'opération shamal en syrie et en irak
est à noter donc au passage là dessus
qu'ils emmanuel macron a annoncé le 17
février le retrait d'ici six mois des
2500 soldats français qui sont présents
au mali dans le cadre de l'opération
barkan des troupes françaises entre 2500
à 3000 soldats resteront cependant
engagés dans d'autres pays du sahel
notamment au burkina faso ou encore au
niger avec toujours l'objectif affiché
par le gouvernement de venir en soutien
aux forces africaines dans la lutte
antiterroriste c'était une mesure
désormais la candidate souhaite
accueillir tous les réfugiés migrants
qui peuvent entrer sur le territoire et
ce sans condition elle va en fait une
liberté totale de circulation et
d'installation sur le territoire
français à tous les migrants c'est une
mesure similaire qui est proposée par
philippe poutou et plus largement
nathalie arthaud défend l'idée d'une
europe totalement débarrassée de ses
frontières il d'ailleurs pas qu'une
europe sans frontières elle juge que le
principe de frontières est un principe
dépasser comme elle l'évoqué dans mon
interview et donc à elle s'oppose à
beaucoup de candidats et notamment et
bien à l'opposé notamment à eghezée mort
qui lui en l'occurrence se dit favorable
à la construction d'un véritable mur et
de véritables frontières tout autour de
l'union européenne 8e mesure désormais
nathalie arthaud souhaite donner la
possibilité à la population de révoquer
donc de destituer de virer en quelque
sorte à tout moment n'importe quel élu
qu'il soit maire député ou encore
président de la république pour révoquer
un élu nathalie arthaud envisage
plusieurs procédures une nouvelle
élection aux municipales ou législatives
suite à des pétitions massive des
manifestations importantes ou encore un
référendum local l'idée globale donc
c'est permettre davantage de contrôle
sur les élus et de pouvoir les changer
plus facilement qu'aujourd'hui si
nécessaire 9e proposition nathalie
arthaud souhaite allonger la durée du
congé paternité pour qu'ils soient
identiques au congé maternité à la
naissance de l'enfant faut savoir qu'en
france actuellement la durée du congé
paternité et de 28 jours 28 jours contre
16 à 26 semaines pour le congé maternité
enfin pour terminer 10e mesure où 10ème
positionnement avec nathalie arthaud il
n'y aurait pas de jeux olympiques d'été
de 2024 à paris en effet pour elle ces
jeux olympiques sont un gaspillage
financier économique ou encore
écologique aujourd'hui le budget de ces
jeux est de plus de 7 milliards d'euros
alors pour finir je veux juste comme
d'habitude vous citer quelques autres
mesures que je peux avoir le temps de
vous expliquer plus en détail mais qui
me paraissent importantes a mentionné
nathalie arthaud veut que l'état paie en
partie ou dans son intégralité le permis
de conduire des jeunes les plus
défavorisés elle souhaite aussi prendre
en compte le vote blanc supprimer le
secret industriel et commercial
interdire la chasse à courre ou encore
mettre fin à l'élevage et l'abattage
intensifs voilà donc pour un aperçu du
programme de nathalie arthaud maintenant
encore une fois c'est très important de
comprendre que dans son cas précis elle
ne souhaite pas être présidente de la
république et ce qu'elle porte c'est
surtout une vision donc la sortie du
capitalisme qui impliquerait beaucoup
plus que ce qui est évoqué juste ici
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qu'elle a
eu l'occasion de développer lorsque je
les ai interviewé il ya quelques jours
du coup ne n'hésitez pas à découvrir
cette interview elle sortira dans les
prochains jours sur cette même chaîne
youtube et plus largement du coup pour
re découvrir les programmes des
candidats ou les interviews face cachée
de tous les candidats rendez vous sur
cette chaîne n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si jamais c'est pas encore le
cas merci pour votre confiance pressante
vous prend vos proches et on se dit ah
très vite